well tonight friends family and
neighbors really in shock over the death
of a young boy and his father in what
police say is a murder-suicide it
happened a sunday on giant oak street
not too far from camino el dorado
parkway and clayton up in north las
vegas 42 year old eddie ramirez shot his
young son and then himself kate houston
spoke to ramirez long-time colleague who
says everybody is still in shock
eddie ramirez lived right across the
street from where another shooting
happened just a few weeks ago but those
two incidents are unrelated neighbors
are concerned at this level of violence
in the area as are friends of ramirez
knowing he was involved i was with him
on friday in my office
did not expect this did not see this
tommy white worked with eddie ramirez at
laborers union local 872 for more than
20 years i can't even believe
that it even happened i'm still numb
over it i'm still trying to process it
white says ramirez was a dedicated
worker and a devoted family man which
makes this even more confusing to those
who knew him he always had a smile on
his face
that's why i think this is hitting us so
hard neighbors are in shock and are now
focused on supporting the family i feel
for the family i really feel i feel bad
for them and
i know it's hard and i hope they can get
through it white is bringing counselors
to union offices this week he encourages
the community to look out for each other
as we approach the holidays pay
attention to the to your coworker pay
attention to
your friend your family what's going on
kate houston live local now
north las vegas police detectives are
still working to piece together exactly
what happened and really could not
provide much more information yet
tonight